cision alors je sais pas le c'est un
débat moral un débat éthique
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce coup-ci seul interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
plusieurs milliers de personnes ont
manifesté aujourd'hui pour la défense
des sans-papiers en france des
rassemblements à paris ou à montreuil à
l'appel de nombreux collectifs ou
personnalités des heurts ont éclaté avec
les forces de l'ordre des manifestations
qui avait été interdite par la
préfecture de police de paris
la poursuite des manifestations aux
états unis contestation parti de
minneapolis qui s'étend maintenant à
plusieurs villes après la mort d'un
afro-américain au cours de son
interpellation lundi ni le couvre feu
dans la ville ni l'arrestation du
policier mis en cause n'ont suffi à
apaiser les tensions
un homme de 19 ans a été abattu à
détroit le tireur est toujours en fuite
les etats unis se retire de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
depuis le début de la pandémie donald
trump accuse l'organisation d'être trop
indulgente avec la chine
l'union européenne appelle washington à
reconsidérer sa décision
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce samedi cette
manifestation de soutien aux
sans-papiers aujourd'hui à paris et dans
quelques villes de france
environ 1 5 mille personnes ont défilé
dans les rues de la capitale mais aussi
à montreuil quelques échauffourées ont
éclaté en milieu d'après midi une
manifestation qui fait suite à l'appel
de 210 collectifs syndicats et même
quelques gilet jaune pour obtenir je
cite des mesures immédiates contre la
envers les plus fragiles face à la crise
sanitaire 92 personnes ont été
interpellées à l'issue de cette
manifestation
voyez les précisions sur place de notre
reporter ni la faa musou place de la
république à paris se sont rassemblés
aux alentours de 15 heures sur la place
de la république
plus de 5000 personnes qui étaient
venues défendre les droits des
sans-papiers à l'appel vous l'avez dit
de plusieurs collectif de syndicats et
même des gilet jaune alors parmi les
manifestants on a surtout vu des sans
papiers qui sont venus demander
plusieurs choses à savoir des tests
systématiques dans les foyers deux
migrants la distribution de masques de
gel ou encore de gand la mise en
isolement systématique des personnes
infectées ou tout simplement et ça c'est
la revendication la plus les importants
qui est le plus revenu c'est la
régularisation des sans-papiers à qui
nous avons entendu nos micros je
proposais les écoutait pas mal bdd
manchester ici qui sont des travailleurs
sans papiers et à partir du moment que
cette pandémie est venu y sont restés à
côté ne sont pas payés ni quand ils sont
dans des foyers et où ils n'ont pas de
ressources
de quoi à vivre et où est ben voilà ils
sont restés bloquer totalement que ça
soit à vivre ou quoi que ce soit
côté santé côté bas ils sont restés à
côté valve a oublié même je vais dire si
le mot me permettre bon voilà donc cette
hausse alors on est venu aujourd'hui
pour montrer notre colère pour montrer
aux français ou à l'état français
donc en fait de nous régulariser notre
but c'est qu'elle demeurait régularisés
et voilà et en fait on est dedans
dans zéro et moment de solidarité voilà
qu'elle soit vivre que ça soit voilà
autres ben voilà on est là pour
manifester montrer au peuple français
tournait d'honneur on est obligé
aujourd'hui pour l'autre citation
malheureusement nous sommes là bon dans
ces pays la france qu'on ne peut dire
donc vous voit tous les monnaies qui
m'oblige est bon en gros c'est pour
notre régularisation
parce qu'on vit en france depuis des
années il y en a qui vit ici pendant 10
ans ou 20 ans sans papiers s'arrêter
tous et surtout des on peut dire des
sanitaires tout ça dont nous sommes
quand même dans une situation vraiment
très très difficile
toutes les personnes qui sort là on est
là à cause des papiers on n'est pas là
qu'on s'est procurées quelqu'un on n'est
pas volé on n'est pas pour gaspé de
quelque chose inversement le pâté pour
travailler toi même tu sais on a
travaillé on est on apprend à des bases
et en italie espagne beaucoup les payes
pour une avance ici
je n'ai pas pu vous l'avez entendu des
sympathiques ont l'impression d'avoir
été particulièrement fragilisé par cette
crise du coronavirus alors la
manifestation a duré une heure sur la
place de la république dans une ambiance
on va dire festive plutôt calme et puis
très vite les forces de l'ordre ont
demandé à la foule de se disperser
puisque comme vous l'avez dit cette
manifestation a été interdite par la
préfecture de police alors des gaz
lacrymogènes ont été tirés à plusieurs
reprises le cortège s'est dirigé au
niveau de l'avenue de la république où
les forces de l'ordre
on a c'est absolument tout le monde ça a
été très difficile pour nous un
journaliste présent ici de filmer ce qui
se passait on a même assisté à des
arrestations à ses muscles et on a vu
deux cars de police remplies de
manifestants qui cognait ovi train pour
eux nous interpeller et systématiquement
quand nos équipes ont essayé de filmer
ça a été très dur très dur de travailler
aujourd'hui et finalement ça a été aussi
durs pour les journalistes de couvrir
cette manifestation que pour les
manifestants de de tenir cette
mobilisation donc la manifestation est
maintenant terminée ici sur la place de
la république mais les organisateurs
appellent à la nouveau rendez vous le 20
juin prochain
lille a famous ou place de la république
à paris on va en parler à présent avec
philippe vardon vice-président du groupe
rassemblement national au conseil
régional de provence alpes côte d'azur
bonsoir philippe vardon merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france tout
d'abord votre réaction à cette
manifestation non autorisée une
manifestation de soutien aux
sans-papiers aujourd'hui il faut
remettre les choses dans leur contexte
il faut voir de quoi il s'agit en
réalité nous avons des gens qui sont
entrés illégalement dans notre pays qui
participent à une manifestation
interdite
est ce que c'est vraiment la meilleure
façon de commencer leurs relations avec
la france puisque comme ils nous l'ont
dit ils veulent leur régularisation
comme si d'ailleurs devenir français
était une sorte de droit et il suffisait
de venir et puis l'eau redevient
français c'est une manifestation
illégale de gens présents illégalement
dans notre pays
je vois d'ailleurs on voit les
interventions de la police mais qui sont
intervenir extrêmement tardive
on a une manifestation de plus de 5000
personnes qui s'est déroulé pendant une
heure elle été annoncé avant même que la
police intervienne
on a vu à de nombreuses reprises et
votre antenne s'en est souvent fait
l'écho beaucoup plus de zèle de la part
notamment de la préfecture de police de
paris et du préfet l'allemand face à
d'autres manifestations
on a vu des airs beaucoup plus martiaux
de la part de messieurs nenez et
castaner et là on a l'impression mais
comme souvent avec ce gouvernement d'un
pouvoir extrêmement faible et d'un
pouvoir laxiste et en réalité
l'intervention est arrivés très
tardivement
je demande moi ce soir à l'issue de ces
affrontements à l'issue de cette
manifestation qui a tourné à l'émeute
combien d'arrestations et puis au delà
combien d'expulsion ces gens sont
présents illégalement sur notre
territoire
ils n'ont pas le droit d'être là en
réalité ils ont encore moins le droit de
manifester cette manifestation était
interdite
je crois qu'il faut en finir avec cette
faiblesse est que la france se fasse
enfin respectés alors j'adore à votre
question il ya eu 92 interpellation est
exactement pourquoi selon vous l'ol
compte pourquoi selon vous cette
manifestation et elle était maintenue
alors que l'on sait que la région ile de
france et en zone orange qu'il faut
respecter certaines mesures sanitaires
on est encore en pleine en pleine
pandémie pourquoi selon vous les
organisateurs ont-ils maintenu cette
manifestation aujourd'hui précisément
ces gens sont dans une relation de défi
à la france je parle là là tout autant
de ces immigrés clandestins qui
manifestent que de tous les réseaux de
l'extrême gauche sans frontiérisme qui
s'articule autour d'eux on a vu dans ces
manifestations
des pancartes on écriture inclusive je
ne crois pas que ce soit ces clandestins
qui les ai rédigé ils sont eux aussi
quelques pas manipuler mis en action par
un certain nombre de réseaux qui
détestent notre pays qui veulent voir
c'est de dissolution de notre identité
continuer et face à ça on a un pouvoir
qui encore une fois fait preuve de
beaucoup de faiblesses face à tout cela
c'est une preuve de beaucoup de
faiblesses face à l'immigration
clandestine
de manière générale vous vous rendez
compte dans la capitale de notre
dans la capitale de la france 5000 e
sans papiers 5000 clandestins qui
manifestent bien normalement il devrait
être arrêté
conduits dans des centres de rétention
et expulser rapidement
c'est le seul message que l'on peut
avoir face à cela parce que ce
comportement n'est pas celui de gens qui
veulent faire corps avec la france qui
veulent s'intégrer s'assimiler comme
nous le défendrons rassemblement
national à notre nation ils sont dans
une agressivité qui est palpable
le premier clandestins qui intervenait à
votre antenne disait nous sommes en
colère mais en colère après qui après
nous après l'état français après les
français mais c'est les français qui
devrait être en colère
nous avons eu au mois d'avril résultant
de la crise sanitaire que nous
connaissons et du confinement 843 mille
demandeurs d'emplois supplémentaires
dans notre pays
huit cent quarante trois mille
demandeurs d'emplois supplémentaires
dans notre pays est aujourd'hui on voit
ces associations ces personnalités 1 les
pétitionnaires professionnels qui n'ont
pour seule préoccupation que le sort de
jean qui encore une fois sont entrés
illégalement se sont maintenus
illégalement dans notre pays mais où
peut-on imaginer cela
où peut-on imaginer cela moi ma
préoccupation elle va d'abord assez 843
mille demandeurs d'emploi français que
l'on compte en plus depuis ce mois
d'avril
philippe vardon parmi ces sans papiers
on le sait il y a des gens qui
travaillent d'ailleurs certains ont
travaillé dans les champs pendant le
confinement pour aider les agriculteurs
qui n'avaient pas de main d'oeuvre
vous parlez de rapatriement en ce moment
on sait que les vols pour l'instant son
sont cloués au sol néanmoins que dites
vous de ce qu'a fait le gouvernement
pour ces personnes justement le premier
ministre a dit qu'il n'avait pas besoin
d'être régularisés de temporairement
alors que faire mais nous avons des
centres de rétention qui sont faits
justement pour être dans cette situation
passagère
parce que quand on est en situation
illégale dans notre pays le parcours
normal devrait être l'arrestation le
placement en centre de rétention et plus
d'expulsions quand on veut devenir
français on passe par la voie légale
quand on veut devenir français on
démontre son envie de participer à la
vie de ce pays
légalement on n'entre pas illégalement
on ne se maintient pas illégalement
neutre
haweij pas illégalement et je pense moi
que ce qui d'ailleurs font travailler
ces clandestins et souvent il faut bien
le reconnaître les exploitent les font
travailler avec des salaires de misère
sont eux aussi grandement responsable et
devraient être jugés de la même façon il
y a encore une fois huit cent quarante
trois mille demandeurs d'emplois
supplémentaires dans notre pays
depuis cette crise sanitaire c'est à eux
que ces emplois devraient aller en
priorité oui évidemment il faut d'abord
rétablir nos frontières pour nous
protéger de cette immigration
clandestine
il faut ensuite faire appliquer nos lois
expulsé ces immigrés clandestins
et puis en matière dans le poids il faut
appliquer la priorité nationale et aussi
faire la chasse aux patrons voyous qui
exploite cette misère humaine
dernière question fait les verts dont
cette manifestation n'a pas vraiment été
couvertes par d'autres médias tout info
qu'en pensez vous pour quelles raisons
vous savez le plus souvent le problème
dans le traitement journalistique n'est
pas tant la tonalité du traitement que
le choix éditorial et faire le choix de
parler ou de ne pas parler d'un sujet
c'est déjà en soi le choix le plus fort
que l'on peut faire effectivement l'on
peut regretter que ce soit d'ailleurs
sur les réseaux sociaux ou bien ce soir
dans l'écran médias nationaux
cette espèce d'omerta voilà les images
que nous voyons votre antenne elles sont
choquantes et sans doute certains
pensent qu'il ne faut pas les montrer
aux français d'un mois je crois qu'on a
toujours tort de ne pas dire la vérité
aux français voilà on a toujours tort de
ne pas montrer les choses telles
qu'elles sont après chacun fera son
jugement sur cette situation
les français peuvent avoir des regards
divergent différents mais au moins que
nous ayons un terrain de discussion qui
soit le même et qu'il soit informé
correctement
merci beaucoup fait et marne ont d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt fluence
au volet politique
a lyon la république en marche à retirer
l'investiture au maire sortant gérard
collomb pour la métropole
un geste en représailles après le
retrait de ce dernier au profit du
candidat de la droite guy marosi
explication est que nous sommes loin un
retour en campagne délicat pour et les
rer après avoir perdu la majorité
absolue à l'assemblée nationale il y a
un de deux semaines le mouvement
présidentiel devra se priver d'une
partie de son ancrage à lyon à l'origine
de cette déconvenue une alliance passée
entre gérard collomb et laurent wauquiez
censé contrer la liste des verts et
leurs alliés de la gauche aux
municipales face à l' avance confortable
des écologistes au premier tour le maire
de lyon a passé un deal avec le
président de la région rhône alpes
auvergne
la droite aura la présidence de la
métropole lyonnaise et laissera à yann
cucherat protégés de l'ex ministre de
l'intérieur est investi par l hérault m
le champ libre jusqu'à l'hôtel de ville
un rapprochement justifié selon
l'ex-ministre d'emmanuel macron par les
circonstances exceptionnelles mais nous
pensons qu'aujourd'hui nous devons nous
réunir
parce que nous vivons des temps
extraordinaires
quand nous avons réfléchi sur les suites
de ce premier tour nous avions choix
nous aurions pu poursuivre
l'accentuation de nos divergences
parfois nos querelles parfois de nos
dissensions
puis nous avions un deuxième principe
que nous pouvions adopté qui était celui
de la responsabilité et celui que nous
avons choisie mais cet arrangement n'a
pas du tout été du goût des marcheurs le
mouvement présidentiel a annoncé qu'il
retirait son investiture à yann cucherat
la ceni dénonce la décision de gérard
collomb et de yann cucherat de s'allier
avec laurent wauquiez etienne blanc et
françois noël buffet pour le second tour
des élections municipales et
métropolitaine elle regrette que là où
le rassemblement des progressistes
aurait dû être la priorité
un tel accord était conclu
unilatéralement en conséquence la cni
retirent leur investiture à gérard
collomb et yann cucherat
ils ne sont donc plus les candidats de
la république en marche pour la
métropole et la ville de lyon
une décision similaire s'appliquera à
l'ensemble des candidats investis par la
république en marche dans les
arrondissements lyonnais et les
circonscriptions de la métropole s'il
décidé à leur tour de s'engager dans le
schéma d'alliance présenté par gérard
collomb est étienne bloque pas de
candidat lrm en lice pour conquérir la
capitale des gaules
qu'à cela ne tienne estime le délégué
générale de la république en marche pour
qui une ligne rouge a été franchie la
république en marche s'est construite
sur le dépassement des clivages qui ont
paralysé la vie politique française
depuis des décennies mais ce dépassement
c'est toujours établi sur la base d'un
socle de valeurs partagées et
indiscutable en choisissant de s'allier
avec les républicains gérard collomb a
franchi une ligne rouge
je ne peux cautionner un tel accord
politique dont valeurs seront toujours
plus importante que quelques sièges dans
un conseil municipal
après paris lyon va vraisemblablement
elle aussi échappé au parti présidentiel
dont les relations avec gérard collomb
se sont bien assombri en 2017 ce dernier
avait pourtant versé une larme de joie
le jour de l'investiture des manuels
macro depuis l'eau a coulé sous les
ponts
aux etats unis la colère contre la
police accusé de violence contre les
afro américains se poursuit malgré le
couvre-feu et l'inculpation pour
homicide involontaire du policier mis en
cause dans la mort d'un afro-américain
lundi de nouvelles manifestations ont eu
lieu l'année dernière c'est la quatrième
nuit consécutive à minneapolis mais
aussi dans d'autres grandes villes du
pays à detroit un homme de 19 ans a été
abattu hier soir au cours d'une
manifestation par un homme au volant
d'une voiture il est toujours en fuite
un retour sur les dernières tensions
regarder
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
situation on ne peut pas laisser la
situation comme ce qui est arrivé à
minneapolis sombrer davantage dans
l'anarchie sombrer davantage dans
l'anarchie et le chaos
et on le comprend très bien c'est très
important je pense pour la famille pour
tout le monde que la mémoire de georges
floyd et souhaite une mémoire parfaite
même georges floride
ducati du jour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
lundi notre nation a assisté à
l'assassinât d'un homme à la télévision
il est scandaleux qu'il ait fallu une
semaine et un tollé national pour enfin
entamer le processus de recherche de la
justice pour georges floyd nous devons
rester vigilants et assurer une enquête
complète et crédible pour garantir que
tous les responsables soient pleinement
traduits en justice
ce meurtre par un policier est un
scandale qui frappe au coeur même de
notre société
mais nous devons garder à l'esprit que
ce seul meurtre n'est que la dernière
manifestation d'un système qui dévalue
si durement la vie des noirs
c'est déjà assez difficile d'approché de
l'anniversaire de la mort de mon fils et
maintenant entendre parler de ce jeune
homme seul a un goût de déjà vu
c'est comme le meurtre de mme office il
avait fondamentalement le même âge
qu'eric
[Musique]
c'est le dernier d'une longue série de
meurtres d'afro-américains non armée
commis par des policiers américains
les autorités américaines doivent
prendre des mesures sérieuses pour
mettre fin à ces meurtres et pour
s'assurer que justice soit faite
lorsqu'il se produise
oui
et
ap
à
[Musique]
les voiliers à présent la réaction de la
présidente des communautés contre les
violences policières
elle dénonce l'impunité qui serait faite
aux forces de l'ordre aux états unis il
souriait littéralement à la caméra alors
qu'il appuyait avec son genou sur le
coup de monsieur floyd il souriait à la
caméra sachant que des gens le film et
il ne se faisait aucun soucis puisqu'il
était plus que certain qu'il sentirait
voilà comment ça se passe à minneapolis
il est essentiel que ces agents de
police soient traduits en justice pour
meurtre
en fait ils font ce qu'ils soient
immédiatement arrêté et pas seulement
poursuivi une des raisons pour
lesquelles les membres de notre
communauté sont tellement contrarié et
que ces policiers font toujours la loi
dans la rue alors que ce sont des
personnes dangereuses
ils font la loi dans la rue ils n'ont
pas été arrêtés alors que si l'un
d'entre nous avaient été filmés tuant
une personne
cet individu attendrait son procès en
prison nous ne pourrons pas apaiser la
communauté s'est tant que ces policiers
n'auront pas été arrêté ces policiers
ont un sentiment d'impunité un sentiment
qu'ils n'auront pas à répondre de leurs
actes
c'est habituel chez eux car ils agissent
en toute impunité
les etats-unis qui ont mis un terme à
leur relation avec l'organisation
mondiale de la santé hier soir au motif
que l'om est serais-je trop indulgente
avec la chine c'est en tout cas ce que
pense donald trump la chine d'où est
partie la pandémie l'union européenne a
appelé washington à changer d'avis
rallia berrada c'était une menace
persistante c'est désormais une réalité
l'amérique de donald trump coupe
unilatéralement les ponts avec
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
à l'origine de cette rupture la
politique de l'om est ce que le
président américain juge trop
complaisante avec la chine depuis le
début de la pandémie de kovy 19e' n'a eu
de cesse d'appeler l'organisation
onusienne a davantage de fermeté nous
avons détaillé les réformes que l' oms
devait engager directement avec la chine
mais l'organisation a refusé à cause de
ce refus a engagé des réformes
nous nous retirons immédiatement de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
allons nous tourner vers d'autres
organisations publiques dans le monde
qui méritent notre aide
le monde a besoin de réponses de la
chine sur le virus
nous avons besoin de transparence avec
893 millions de dollars apportés sur la
période 2010 2019 soit environ 15% du
budget de l'om est ce les etats-unis en
sont le premier bailleur de fonds loin
devant la chine et ses 86 millions la
contribution américaine va
essentiellement en afrique et au
moyen-orient qui seront donc les
premiers impactés par le retrait des
états unis un retrait qui constitue un
sérieux revers pour la santé mondiale
juge de son côté le ministre allemand de
la santé
ils appellent l'union européenne a
alloué des fonds plus importants à ems
il s'agit d'un sérieux revers pour la
santé mondiale
si l'on veut que l'om espèce à l'avenir
il faut engager des réformes et l'union
européenne se doit d'avoir un rôle de
leader et de s'engager davantage
financièrement ce sera l'une des
priorités du ministère fédéral de la
santé
au cours de notre présidence européenne
la décision de donald trump survient
alors que la pandémie de covile 19
continue à faire des ravages aux états
unis le pays le plus touché tant nombre
de morts qu de cas a franchi mercredi la
barre des cent mille décès
en amérique du sud le brésil et
maintenant le cinquième pays qui
enregistre le plus grand nombre de morts
28 mille décès depuis le début de
l'épidémie
nouvelle journée noire hier avec 1124
décès en 24 heures dans le pays plus de
460 5000 personnes sont infectées par le
coronavirus fatoumata bacchini des
tombes à perte de vue qui témoigne de
l'ampleur de la pandémie au brésil pas
un jour sans une longue liste de
victimes du coronavirus pas un jour sans
enterrement rien que ces dernières 24
heures plus d'un millier de morts ont
été comptabilisés dans tout le pays
les jetez vos autres comme on est cadre
des sources pejcinovic enough
nous avons appris que mon oncle était
soupçonné d'avoir le coc vite 19
il a été envoyé à l'hôpital de
bellavista deux heures après y avoir été
admis il est décédé d'un arrêt cardiaque
mais je pense vraiment que nous devons
être plus attentifs aux copies 2009 car
nous réalisons vraiment ce que c'est
quand cela m'est arrivé sur ce
territoire de plus de 200 millions
d'habitants les favelas sont en première
ligne face au corona virus qui se
propage à toute vitesse en raison de la
promiscuité et du manque d'installations
sanitaires
à tel point que les autorités craignent
que ces quartiers pauvres ne deviennent
des foyers particulièrement dense de
kovy de 19 pour le moment le coville 19
n'est pas la première des préoccupations
pour ces familles elle n'y croiront que
lorsque l'un des leurs décèdera de la
maladie c'est dur à comprendre pour les
gens c'est quelque chose que nous
entendons beaucoup mais nous essayons de
combattre tout cela en donnant des
informations en luttant contre les fake
news en transformant un sujet politique
en quelque chose de plus rationnel qui
résonne auprès de la population
pour l'heure faute de tests disponibles
les autorités peinent à établir avec
précision le nombre de victimes et les
chiffres officiels restent bien en deçà
de la réalité
[Musique]
et dans moins d'une heure maintenant
space x va retenter de lancer dans
l'espace deux astronautes de la nasa
après un report mercredi dernier à cause
de mauvaises conditions météorologiques
si la société privée y parvient cette
fois ce sera une nouvelle ère dans la
conquête spatiale
les détails en images 17 minutes avant
son lancement officiel
la nouvelle tombe la nasa et space x
décide d'annuler le décollage de crewe
dragon en raison des conditions
météorologiques
prochaine date de lancement prévue donc
ce soir la nouvelle ère du transport
spatial aura bien lieu à l'initiative de
l'entrepreneur milliardaire hillen musk
space x est la première société privée à
envoyer des astronautes dans l'espace
de quoi rendre aux américains leur
autonomie de l'accès à l'espace c'est la
première fois depuis neuf ans que les
états unis lanceront une fusée de
conception américaine sans dépendre des
russes depuis 2011 et le dernier vol de
la navette spatiale atlantis aucune
fusée américaine n'a envoyé d'humain
dans l'espace une page de l'histoire se
tourne donc et une du transport spatial
s'ouvre cette capsule va notamment
permettre l'ouverture de nouveaux
marchés de services de transport
spatiaux un enjeu primordial pour ilan
musk qui depuis dix-huit ans travaille à
faire de space x un acteur spatiale
majeur mais un enjeu également pour
donald trump qui avait fait de
l'indépendance spatiale une promesse de
campagne
un succès stratégique attendus pour le
président américain
et nous suivrons bien sûr cet événement
en direct sur notre antenne
restez avec nous le journal c'est dans
un peu plus de trente minutes
et
[Musique]
cela fait maintenant plusieurs je dirais
décennies presque que la france ou
financent sa recherche et son
enseignement supérieur à quoi est-ce que
vous attribuez ce manque de moyens c'est
un un problème politique au sens où ça
serait à gauche devant le projet
politique
la recherche n'a pas la place qu'elles
devraient avoir parce que la recherche
est un élément central dans la prise en
cours